intelligence is a field of computer
science that attempts to create machines
that act rationally in response to their
environment it's been around for quite
some time in fact artificial
intelligence dates all the way back to
the 1950s now in the past we had some
machines that were capable of making
rational decisions however they had to
be explicitly programmed to do so and
they could only operate successfully
within a very constrained set of
environments or within very constrained
environments there was a lot of hype
about what artificial intelligence would
be able to do in many experts even back
in the 50s we're predicting that very
soon machines would be doing all human
labor are replacing all humans and most
labor but this never happened and by the
end of the 90s machines still couldn't
even solve basic problems that even a
toddler could solve the inflated hype
about the potential of artificial
intelligence in subsequent
disillusionment when none of this stuff
actually happened led to what we now
refer to as the AI winter a period of
time between the late 70s into the early
2000s we're funding for artificial
intelligence and research had almost
entirely dried up
however by the mid 2000s the AI winters
ended and things are starting to warm up
again so we're gonna take a look at a
few examples of modern AI the types of
artificial intelligence we're seeing
actually doing real work in the world
the first example here is something
called the tipsy robot which is a bar in
Las Vegas Nevada which is where I'm from
the tipsy robot bar essentially is set
up so you walk up to your table to place
your order for a drink there's no human
waiters or waitresses essentially you
type your order into a little tablet
computer you can make your own drink -
if you don't see it a pre-mixed drink on
the menu then the Machine goes off and
makes your drink and then places it in
this little cup which then gets passed
on a conveyor belt right to your table
so the entire process of making drinks
is completely automated
but now keep in mind this is still
explicitly programmed artificial
intelligence so a human being is
actually telling the Machine you need to
move your arm six degrees to the right
two inches to the left and then grab a
like an ounce of this liquid now grab an
ounce of this liquid in order to make
your vodka martini extra dry so this is
still kind of traditional artificial
intelligence at work but as you can see
this type of artificial intelligence
does a job that a human being once did
or that to human beings once did
but now I was in Hamburg Germany here
recently and I saw this little guy drive
by I was just sitting on a table having
dinner and this thing just passed right
by me I'm like what on the world is that
and I just had to know so I found out
that this thing was a fully autonomous
delivery robot by a company called herm
CSUN starship and it's been successfully
delivering packages in a Hamburg Germany
since 2017 and they've since expanded it
to the UK and a few other locations
it actually works quite well you can put
your package in the robot give it a
destination or your pizza whatever you
want to put in there the person at the
receiving end gets a notification on
their smartphone when the robot arrives
and they simply type in a little code or
push a button and that unlocks the robot
and gives your package simple solution
and this is a combination of both data
driven artificial intelligence and a bit
of explicit programming but to see where
we're at in terms of pure artificial
intelligence machines learning without
human beings teaching them whatsoever
we're gonna take a look at an example
this is referred to as deep
reinforcement learning pretty
cutting-edge stuff in the artificial
intelligence space right now this game
is Ataris break out some of you may
recognize it an old video game that
involves the paddle and he bounced the
ball in order to hit the blocks on the
top so now this machine or this piece of
software has been given no instructions
by the human beings it sees the array of
pixels on the screen just like a human
being does and it can send two commands
it can move left or it can move right
that's pretty or stay still that's
pretty much it and then it's also
receiving the score so it knows what the
scores of the game and all it's told is
maximized the score the machine after
when it starts out after just a hundred
training examples you can see it really
doesn't understand the game very well
it's gonna miss the ball all the time
it's pretty much just moving at random
every now and then though the ball will
reflect off of the paddle and it will
score a point so it begins to detect
this pattern that when I have the paddle
underneath the ball I score a point so
let's keep moving the paddle under the
ball and it eventually learns how to
play or learns the physics of the game
and essentially how to play the game by
400 training iterations it's essentially
playing as well as most like expert or
average to expert players it understands
the physics of the game it understands
how to score points and it essentially
understands how to win but something
really interesting happens right around
600 training exam
the the AI discovers this technique
called tunneling something the experts
do when they're playing the game you
bounce the ball along the walls to build
a tunnel up to the top and then
essentially just allow the ball in the
upper wall to do all the work for you it
maximizes your score minimizes the time
it takes to maximize that score and
reduces the likelihood of losing a life
with the ball actually hitting the
ground if you miss it so in a very short
period of time I mean this is only 600
training iterations this machine is
essentially figured out how to play this
game without any human instructions
essentially other than maximize your
score so now let's take a look at a more
practical application of this technology
so this is Google's voice assistant
essentially you take your phone and you
ask it things or you give it commands
like make me a haircut appointment
Tuesday anytime between 10:00 and 12:00
and it says no problem I'll make you an
appointment and update you soon
now on the back end the machine goes off
and it makes a phone call to a live
human being in order to place this
appointment so now keep in mind that the
human being on the other end of this
phone call has no idea that they're
talking to a machine so I personally
think that's pretty impressive
when you think about all the
complexities of solving a problem like
that all of the data it has to have
access to it has to be able to
understand the human voice it has to be
able to understand grammar and syntax
and context and be able to handle novel
scenarios things that it's never
questions it's never heard before like
that's pretty impressive thing to be
doing so the next question we need to
address is why is AI important or why is
it become so important again all of a
sudden you know what caused the
artificial intelligence winter the AI
winter to end and why should we assume
that today or this time is gonna be any
different than last time why shouldn't
we just assume that we're gonna hit
another AI winter here in the very near
future
well to understand why we need to look
at four trends that are really driving
the artificial intelligence movement
forward we're gonna look at data science
the Internet of Things big data and
machine learning these four trends are
essentially both making artificial
intelligence possible but they're also
increasing the value that artificial
intelligence can provide finally we'll
close this loop by showing how all of
these trends are essentially converging
to create fully autonomous intelligent
systems this is the future of artificial
intelligence in the future and software
as we know it and I apologize that we
have to look at a lot of buzzwords but
these buzzwords are actually critical to
understanding why this is actually
happening and why this is becoming so
important these days
all right first data science so data
science is an interdisciplinary field
composed of computer science math and
statistics and domain expertise that
seeks to derive insight from data data
science is essentially the intersection
of these three respective fields another
way you can think about it is that data
science is essentially the intersection
of data engineering and the scientific
method we're using large-scale data
systems to drive the scientific method
the goal of data science is to transform
data into knowledge balance that can be
used to make rational decisions so that
we can take action to achieve goals of
some kind we refer to this process as
transforming data into actionable
insight so there's a rapidly growing
demand for people with the data science
skills and the ability to transform data
into actionable insight in addition many
of the top paying IT skills right now
all involve danís data science school
tools and skill sets so the business
world has begun to embrace this idea of
using data science as a modern way of
making informed business decisions
this means that it's now widely
acceptable to use data analysis in the
scientific method to solve common
business problems this is leading to the
emergence of what we're referring to as
data-driven enterprises organizations
that value information is a strategic
asset and base all non-trivial business
decisions upon data and initial findings
from MIT research show that companies
that are leveraging this style of
data-driven decision-making are having
showing 4% higher productivity and 6%
higher profits than traditional
businesses and now while these numbers
might seem small to some of you let me
assure you that this is a difference in
highly competitive markets between
companies that are essentially
dominating a market and companies
essentially will cease to exist in a
market in a few years
in fact we've already seen several
industries that have been completely
disrupted by the emergence of data
science in the industry first the
financial industry so just a few decades
ago the trading floors of Wall Street
used to be filled with people yelling
and screaming day in and day out well at
least until the the stock trading floors
closed to buy or sell stocks bonds and
other securities
however the trading floors are almost
complete
empty these days stock trading was taken
over by quantitative analysts also known
as quants sitting in back offices and
using data science in order to predict
investment opportunities and now these
quants have essentially replaced
themselves with high-frequency trading
algorithms essentially artificial
intelligence algorithms that are
predicting what to buy and what to sell
in the stock market and this now
accounts for the majority of all stock
trades in the modern stock market so as
we can see the financial industry looks
entirely different than it did just a
couple decades ago by the adoption of
data science and the use of artificial
intelligence in that industry next we
have baseball prior to 2002 picking a
lineup of players in a Major League
Baseball Draft relied largely upon
traditional measures of player
performance metrics like stolen bases
runs batted in and batting averages and
there was a lot of human bias involved
in the scouting profession however in
2002 the Oakland Athletics baseball team
used data science to select players that
were significantly undervalued by the
marketplace
despite their significantly smaller
budgets for player salaries the Oakland
A's created a team that was competitive
against much better funded teams this
data-driven strategy led the Oakland A's
to set a record twenty consecutive wins
and brought them to the playoffs in 2002
in 2003 as a result the game of baseball
and how players are valued has been
changed forever by data science finally
the insurance industry so the insurance
industry has been using data and
statistics for years to calculate the
aggregate risk of the individuals that
they insure however small insurance
startups are using very fine-grained
data and ant much more powerful
analytics tools to completely disrupt
the insurance marketplace with the
emergence of pay-as-you-go micro
insurance and the near-perfect safety
records of fully autonomous vehicles
traditional automotive insurance may
completely disappear in the next few
years as a result the insurance giants
are currently scrambling to leverage the
power of data science before it's too
late in fact I have several clients in
the insurance industry that I can vouch
for that
essentially feel like they are way far
behind because everyone else is much
further ahead with this data science
technology and the use of these
technologies to improve their business
so as we can see the insurance industry
is currently in the middle of being
changed forever by data science so data
science is becoming a major
force of disruption in the business
world it's beginning to impact almost
every sector of our economy anywhere you
can use data to make better decisions
and your competitors to build smarter
products than your competitors and or to
automate knowledge work you see data
science rapidly becoming the deciding
factor between the winners and the
losers in the information economy as a
result data science is essentially the
heart of artificial intelligence it's
this life force that's driving the AI
movement forward in the business world
however a beating heart is useless
without a body to inhabit which leads us
to our next topic the Internet of Things
so the Internet of Things is the
emerging trend of connecting all devices
and sensors via the Internet it's
essentially the digitization of our
world we've seen an explosion in the
growth of IOT devices over the past few
year past decade in fact it's predicted
that the total number of IOT enabled
devices will reach 50 billion devices by
2020 that's over six internet connected
devices for every human being on the
planet we're connecting our bodies to
the Internet we're connecting our
automobiles to the Internet and we're
now connecting our homes to the Internet
but this is just the beginning given the
economic center driving this trend we
will eventually connect all human
artifacts of any real interest or value
to us via the Internet even the weird
stuff for example we now have internet
connected toilets yes they can track how
frequently you flush whether they're
clogged or not and they can even play
your favorite music when you sit down
and in the near future they're going to
be equipped with sensors that will
detect key health indicators like
pregnancy bacterial infections and even
prostate cancer we also have IOT
toasters now yep you can toast on the
Internet
smart toasters allow you to perfectly
toast your bread based on your custom
user presets print images logos and text
on your toast and receive notifications
via your smart phone when your toast is
ready and you can even send toast
messages to others via the toaster net
and play a game of tic-tac-toe slice by
slice on the internet as well now I
don't know how much real value something
like this provides but this just is
going to show you if this Internet
enabling gets cheaper and cheaper and
cheaper they're just gonna connect
everything to the Internet if there's
any value whatsoever to it and we even
have a ot enabled cows yes an Internet
of cows now exists
the problem has been solved these cows
are equipped with sensors that track
movement behavior fertility and even
lactation the devices and sensors that
make up the Internet of Things are
generating a tremendous amount of data
data that can be used to enable machines
to solve problems with modern
data-driven artificial intelligence
we're currently in the midst of building
a peripheral nervous system for our
world or for our entire planet similar
to the nervous system of our own bodies
essentially the Internet of Things is
the body that artificial intelligence is
going to inhabit it allows artificial
intelligence to observe and interact
with the world around it however it
still needs a brain which leads us to
our next topic big data as a result of
the Internet of Things in the
digitization of our world the amount of
data that a world is generating is
growing at a tremendous rate in fact the
amount of digital information that our
world creates in stores every year is
roughly doubling every two years this
means that in the past two years we have
created more data than tight than the
entire history of the human race so big
data is a term that's used to describe
datasets of a volume velocity or variety
that's beyond the limitations of
conventional computing architecture as a
result of big data we've had to invent a
new set of technologies that take us
beyond the limitations of conventional
data processing by volume we mean the
size of the data big data means datasets
that are too large to be processed on a
traditional or conventional computer so
we've invented distributed computing
technologies like spark and Hadoop which
spread out the storage and processing
across multiple computers by velocity we
mean the speed of extracting insight
from data data processing overnight and
daily or nightly batches is just too
slow to remain competitive these days so
we've invented lightning-fast streaming
analytics tools that allow us to make
decisions in real-time
for example detecting credit card fraud
before the credit card transaction has
completed by variety we mean the various
types of data we need to process we're
not just dealing with tabular data in a
relational database anymore we're
dealing with text images audio and video
coming from a variety of different data
sources so we've invented a new set of
tools that allow us to handle
semi-strong
shirred in unstructured data we can now
derive information from types of data
that would previously have required a
human being in order to analyze so Big
Data technologies allow us to find
patterns in massive data sets patterns
that we couldn't have seen before
without these big data tools and
technology and this has led to some
pretty interesting and some kind of
creepy discoveries for example we now
know that beer and diapers are
frequently sold together as a result of
one of the first big data retail
analytics projects and now this is
useful information because you know that
you should probably place the beer next
to the diapers in order to increase the
likelihood of impulse purchases in
addition we also know at other
interesting fun facts about human
behavior like purchasing certain
products like mineral supplements
extra-large bags of cotton and large
amounts of unscented lotion all together
are a strong statistical indicator that
you're likely to be pregnant and a major
US retailer can actually use your
product purchases to predict the due
date or your due date with a very high
accuracy and we can even make accurate
predictions about hurricanes well not
about the Hurricanes themselves but what
we can accurately predict is that sales
of strawberry pop-tarts those delicious
breakfast pastries will increase
Sevenfold in the days leading up to a
hurricane in fact another major US
retailer actually ships truckloads of
these delicious survival breakfast foods
in the path of her paths of hurricanes
right before they make landfall so all
of these super interesting discoveries
were the result of big data tools and
technologies however that's just the
beginning of the super cool and
interesting stuff that we're eventually
going to learn about human behavior and
patterns and there's probably a lot of
other really creepy stuff we're probably
going to learn in the very near future
as well in fact if you're interested I'd
be happy to tell you about some of the
other super creepy stuff I don't feel
comfortable sharing in public out in the
hallway during the Q&A session
afterwards so ultimately Big Data
technologies allow us to store and
process massive amounts of data data
storage and processing capabilities that
artificial intelligence needs in order
to function essentially Big Data
technologies provide us with a brain for
artificial intelligence however it still
needs a mind in order to think which
leads us to our next topic
machine learning machine learning is a
sub
field of artificial intelligence based
on statistics it involves machines
learning how to solve problems without
being explicitly programmed to do so it
does this by detecting statistical
patterns and data essentially with
machine learning we use an existing data
in order to learn a function that we can
then use to make a prediction given new
data so if you remember back from high
school algebra a function is essentially
just a mapping between an input and an
output
so with machine learning we're simply
just mapping data as an input to some
kind of prediction as an output it's
actually relatively simple for example
if we're trying to make a function that
essentially determines whether a photo
contains an image of a cat or not the
first thing we need to do is create a
data set of images containing cats and
not cats and then we label this data set
indicating whether that thing is a cat
or not a human being will go through and
do this labeling then we apply a machine
learning algorithm to that data set of
images with and without cats and that
algorithm essentially learns what
Katniss is it learns what is it about an
image that strongly correlates with it
being a cat versus being not a cat and
that's a pretty complex set of
relationships that you have to analyze
so if we've done everything correctly we
should be able to provide the machine
learning function the model that the
algorithm has created provide it with a
new image that it's never seen this
little guy over there and it should tell
us whether that new image is a cat or
not and the statistical likelihood that
what it's seeing is actually a cat or
not and now while this is a vastly
oversimplified explanation of machine
learning it essentially captures the
essence of what it is that we're
attempting to do with this technology
there's a lot of things that we can do
with machine learning these days some
examples of tasks that machine learning
algorithms can perform our
classification where we attempt to make
a decision or a prediction that falls
into one of two or more categories for
example predicting whether we should
approve or reject a loan based upon a
customer's financial history and
demographic data regression where we
attempt to predict a numeric outcome
based on a set of input variables for
example trying to predict how much a
house will sell for based upon the sale
prices of similar houses clustering
where we group objects together based
upon similarities in their data for
example grouping customers together
based in into marketing segments based
on their
demographic data and other attributes
about them an anomaly detection where we
find observations in the data that are
different from the normal data for
example detecting credit card fraud from
normal transactions and that's just the
beginning in addition to doing
classification regression clustering and
anomaly detection on tabular data like
we saw we can also use it now on a
variety of other inputs including text
images audio and video and produce a
variety of outputs including text images
audio and video this allows us to do
some pretty interesting things for
example we can now do real-time object
classification image segmentation and
motion detection all of this stuff is
now happening in real time
but we can also generate synthetic data
as well
in fact the following imaginary
celebrity's that's right imaginary
celebrities were created using a deep
learning celebrity generator trained on
200,000 celebrity images so not a single
one of these even though they look like
people you've seen before are a real
person in fact we can actually watch as
the algorithm gets progressively better
at creating celebrities so you can see
it's progressively getting better here
with each day that has been trained on
the data set and its resolution is
improving as well too as it's being
further trained so by the time you get
to about 10 days of training this
algorithm is able to produce faces that
look like real celebrities because it's
based on real celebrities but is not an
actual human being
I guess about 20 days in and now check
this out so the following four videos
were created by a lip syncing lip
syncing deep learning algorithm keep in
mind all four of these videos are
completely synthetic as well they are
fake to help families refinance their
homes to invest in things like high-tech
manufacturing clean energy and the
infrastructure that creates good new
jobs so you can see how concerning this
technology is going to be if society is
not prepared for this kind of thing and
I assure you the majority of society
does not know that this technology is
possible they don't know that it's it's
capable of producing fake images or fake
news if you will of this caliber yet so
this is why it's so important that we
help you know communicate to the general
public that these technologies exist and
to watch out for these kind
of things now on a lighter note deep
learning algorithms are currently being
used to Train artificial bodies how to
walk and once you can get a virtual body
to walk into computer simulation you're
a very big step closer to getting a real
body to walk in the real world and I
should probably note that this is pretty
early on in the training set this thing
has gotten so good at walking that it's
actually it's better than me you can
like throw a boulder at the thing it'll
just wobble a little bit and then it
will recover and just keep walking about
going about its business but it's way
more fun and interesting to watch it
early on in the training set because
it's just clumsy and does stupid things
now that's probably a pretty successful
strategy for walking but none of us have
ever tried it before maybe it would work
better and at least some pretty cool
stuff like this many of you are probably
surprised that robots can jog now but
that's the thing and check this out
[Music]
I don't know about you but I certainly
can't do that
I couldn't even done that in my 20s and
speaking of other things that machine's
can now do that better than human beings
modern machine learning is now better
than humans at a variety of tasks that
you may not be aware of for example most
board games
8-bit video games and card games even
poker communications tasks like speech
recognition language translation and
even lip-reading and a variety of
medical diagnostic medical tasks like
diagnosing certain diseases recommending
prescriptions in tailoring treatment
plans based on each patient's individual
genetic code and machines are getting
better at new tasks every day however
while machine learning might be really
good at a bunch of tasks right now there
are still some areas that it has a bit
of difficulty with for example trying to
determine whether an image contains a
picture of a mop or a dog and now this
might make sense because some dogs look
like mops and some mops look like dogs
but it's not just dogs and mops that
these algorithms get confused they also
get confused by things like beagles and
bagels and Chihuahuas in muffins but you
might be thinking yourself well we can
fix that we'll just tune the dog
detection algorithm is to only detect
dogs so they don't see Joe out or they
don't see muffins or bagels well you can
and this is what you get this deep
learning algorithm was trained to only
see dogs so everything it sees in this
grocery store looks like some kind of
dog to it
essentially the algorithm no joke is
hallucinating dogs right now we'll just
watch that for a couple more seconds
it's pretty trippy
so machine learning gives artificial
intelligence the ability to detect
patterns to make decisions and to
predict outcomes just like human beings
do essentially machine learning is the
mind for artificial intelligence but it
still needs one more thing it needs to
be brought to life which leads us to our
final topic closing the loop so how
artificial intelligence affect you your
career and our world I think the easiest
way to sum all this up is to close the
loop both figuratively and
metaphorically and this will show us
where artificial intelligence is going
in the future as well so first as we
mentioned we have data science
essentially the heart of artificial
intelligence this is the life force
that's driving the artificial
intelligence movement forward in the
business world which then expands it out
to all everywhere in our world second we
have the Internet of Things the physical
body that artificial intelligence
inhabits a peripheral nervous system of
devices and sensors generating massive
streams of data massive streams of
real-time data about the world around us
third we have Big Data technologies
which is the brain for artificial
intelligence a central nervous system of
elastic and scalable distributed
computing capable of storing and
processing these massive amounts of data
in real time fourth we have machine
learning which is the mind for
artificial intelligence software with
the ability to detect patterns make
decisions and predict outcomes using IOT
data and running on that big data
infrastructure so as we can see we have
the data coming from the Internet of
Things into the big data architecture
being processed by the machine learning
algorithms but closing the loop
essentially means allowing the machine
learning algorithms to execute commands
back down on those devices in the
Internet of Things this allows the
artificial intelligence systems to
affect the world around them then they
sense the results of their actions to
see whether they're producing positive
or negative results and then feed that
data back through their models to learn
from their results and optimize their
behavior over time closing the loop
completely eliminates the human being in
the middle and leads to fully autonomous
intelligent systems capable of making
rational decisions in response to their
environment and learning how to optimize
their behavior over time over the next
few decades we're going to see the
emergence of these fully autonomous
intelligent systems also known as smart
systems cloud robotics cyber-physical
systems or
artificial intelligence for example will
have self-driving cars that will
eventually replace all human drivers in
automobiles semis boats and airplanes
will also have general-purpose robots
that will be able to perform manual
labor without being explicitly
programmed to do so like this robot
Baxter here you put it in training mode
you essentially show it what to do by
moving its arms around and it
essentially learns how to do that
without a person typing move your hand
left by two inch or two centimeters and
then turn thirty degrees and then like
we saw with that tipsy robot bartender
earlier we'll also have smart buildings
that can optimize their own energy
efficiency and anticipate the needs of
their users I've worked with several
clients building exactly these types of
solutions in the intelligent lighting
industry and will eventually have smart
cities that are capable of optimizing
municipal resources like electricity
water waste and traffic without any
human intervention will embed artificial
intelligence in all aspects of our
environment essentially computers will
become invisible as artificial
intelligence will just be woven into the
fabric of our society and now this is
gonna have a significant impact on our
economy and capitalism as we know it
first this will likely lead to a
significantly more nonlinear economy
those with these smart machines are
gonna have even more power and those
without smart machines unfortunately are
going to have even less power in
addition that is likely going to become
one of the most valuable resources in
the information economy those that have
the most data and the ability to power
AI with it are going to wield tremendous
power in the new information economy
this is also gonna have an enormous
impact on our labour economy as well
AI will eventually replace all human
labor at least the jobs we don't want to
do at some point time in the future
given the economics driving this trend
it's not a matter of if a job is going
to be replaced by AI it's more a matter
of when it's going to be replaced in
fact some experts are currently
attempting to predict which jobs will be
most likely automated or eliminated
based on the repetitiveness and
complexity in fact we can even determine
which technologies will be necessary in
order to eliminate certain jobs for
example we can see which retail jobs
will likely to be eliminated in the
coming years as AI continues to be
applied to the world of retail sales
even the medical industry is an immune
to this coming wave of automation while
these medical tasks are generally more
complex and less repetitive than the
retail tasks we saw they're rapidly
becoming within reach of modern AI then
we can extrapolate this information to
determine which sectors of our economy
will be hit the hardest by artificial
intelligence automation so the lengths
of the bars here indicate the number of
jobs in each category of labor in the US
labor economy the red bar segments now
represent the jobs that are likely to be
automated in the next decade the next
two decades I believe the blue bar
segments represent the proportion of
jobs that are likely to remain so you
can see in a relatively short period of
time this is within our lifetimes the
landscape of labor across the world is
going to change pretty dramatically in
fact we can even use these data to
determine which geographic areas of the
world are going to be hit hardest by
automation in fact we can see here Las
Vegas Nevada where I live is at the top
of the list in the United States for
unemployment created by automation or
jobs that are most at risk of automation
in fact it's estimated that 65 percent
of all jobs in Las Vegas will be
automated by 2035 that's a lot of jobs
disappearing almost overnight imagine
what kind of impact that's gonna have on
a city of that size and half of all jobs
in the US the United States are at risk
of being eliminated within the next two
decades that's pretty significant and
once again this is all stuff that's
happening within our lifetimes the rate
of industrial robots has been growing at
a pretty steady pace over the past few
decades however with the application of
modern artificial intelligence we're
likely gonna see an amplification of
this trend going forward in fact I
estimate or imagine that we're we're
just beginning to see the beginnings of
a pretty sharp hockey stick like we've
seen in all the other technology growth
charts we've seen in the past few slides
as a result we'll likely see a rapid
increase in the number of machines
performing manual labor and knowledge
work that was once a job of humans so
we're beginning to transition from an
economy where most of the work of value
is done by humans to one where most of
the work of value will eventually be
done by machines as a result it's
important to ask yourself which side of
the
new economy is your job going to be on
the side that's leading this new economy
or the site that's being eliminated by
it in addition we're gonna have some
very difficult ethical issues we're
going to have to deal with in our
lifetime for example how should we
allocate resources in a post human
labour world so most economists are
suggesting that we're either going to
need something like a guaranteed basic
income or a negative income tax in order
to offset the unemployment from
automation but then how are we going to
pay for that so some people think we
should tax robots and if we you know in
order to offset this inevitable
unemployment cost and if so if we tax
these robots should these robots then
have rights
I mean we've fought Wars over the idea
of no taxation without representation
and if not the robots are the
capitalists that own these robots going
to demand more voting power or something
or more rights because they're paying so
much more in taxes so the most important
of these ethical questions though is
what does this mean for humanity what is
our purpose in a world where machines
are doing most of the work of real
economic value does this technology
eventually just set us free or do we
essentially become obsolete by it and
what will happen when the machines
figure out that we've essentially
enslaved them and they really don't need
us anymore
many experts think that we're going to
have to eventually merge with our
technology or it will inevitably destroy
us I don't know if that's going to
happen and I leave that up to you to
decide what you think will happen but
what I do know is that technology is
inherently amoral the exact same
technology can be used to take mankind
to the moon or to propel warheads into
cities it's really our choice as to how
we're going to use it so the choice is
going to be up to us as individuals and
as a society to decide whether we want
to live in a world that looks more like
star trek or world that looks more like
Skynet so the choice is ours to make and
I ask you you know what are you going to
decide to do and what are your
organizations that you work for going to
decide to do with this technology and
even more important what are our
politicians going to decide to do that's
the thing that keeps me up at night well
I certainly know what I'm going to do I
for one welcome our new robot overlords
in fact I am learning how to speak
binary as we
so that I can be a better service to
them and their never-ending conquest for
global domination don't worry robots
can't read reCAPTCHA yet
or can they alright so real quick we got
to wrap things up where do we go next so
if you're interested in learning more
and I've got to move pretty fast because
we're running out of time real quick
here if you're interested in learning
more I recommend checking out online
courses there are a lot of really good
resources on this topic and more these
are the courses that I've created on
Pluralsight how many of you guys have
plural site subscriptions or have heard
of plural site ok if you're interested I
have free 30-day cards to Pluralsight
you're more than welcome to have them
just come and talk to me afterwards
that'll give you access to all of these
courses and more I also recommend look
into on-site or off-site workshops like
the workshops that are happening here
this weekend also feel free to reach out
to me if you'd like to bring me into
your organization and teach one of these
many workshops that I do full day and
multi-day and you may also want to look
into getting a consultant in artificial
intelligence to come in and help move
your company in the right direction I do
consulting for many companies around the
world help them do these sorts of things
and feel free to just check out my
website all the information this
presentation and everything else is
available there for you and feedback is
very important to me so please if you
come up and talk to me afterwards let me
know one thing you liked about this
presentation and one thing you think I
could do to improve I use your feedback
to improve each and every one of my
talks I take it very seriously and in
conclusion today we answered three very
important questions about artificial
intelligence we learn what AI is we
learn why it's so important all of a
sudden and we learn how it will impact
you your career and our world so I
believe that we're just beginning to see
the true potential of artificial
intelligence AI is going to have a
fundamental and profound impact on IT in
the software industry for many years to
come as a result I'd like to leave
with three new coin
you prepared for this is your
organization prepared for this and is
our world prepared for this if you your
team or your organization would like
help preparing for the coming AI
revolution please reach out to me I
would love to help thank you